herzlich willkommen zu meinem heutigen
video leute heute wieder zusammen mit
spd ja leute wir spielen heute mal
wieder ein google play spielt ihr kennt
wahrscheinlich dass mittlerweile alle
den rahmen der kampagne deshalb hier
werbevideo dies dass wir spielen heute
nochmal den reaktionstests den ich auch
schon zusammen mit diana gespielt habe
aber heute habe ich einen gegner der
sich als ebenbürtig sieht also ich sag
mal so jana habt hält das also
übertrieben knapp nicht also es war
wirklich so 19 910 habe ich den
entscheidenden punkt gemacht und ich bin
mir sicher dass ich gewinnen werde dass
du gewinnen willst ja da haben wir
erklärt nähe gelegen wieder los das ist
die gleiche elf wie beim letzten mal
davon machen aber im zweiten part war
das hat voll bock gemacht hat wir drehen
uns zueinander und es geht einfach darum
wieder fragen zu beantworten oder wir
beginnen spiele einrichten wir nehmen
die default einstellung okay wenn du
traurig sauer auf die taste alt er war
als ok sowie einzelne für mich wir
spielen bis zehn werde ich sagen es sei
denn es geht so schnell da
ja ja ja die sind alter schwede wachsen
schnell bekämpfen er ist da hinten aus
dem fenster ich habe eigentlich
unglaubliche arroganz versetzt sich dann
trotzdem raten zu kartieren einer linie
muss man drücken
yahoo
die ganze zeit schlecht waren sind
wieder vier in einer linie
hier in einer linie von ali
gerne der neuen linie das hätte es
gesagt du hättest ja weil ich habe junge
trägt auch eine karte ganz normales
spiel gewinnen er ist es auch richtig
schwierig so schnell wie die alle kommen
oder willst du das was du hast du was
bei junge trierer sogar ne yo ich habe
nichts gehört nichts zu preis stimmt das
abc war das ist richtig schwierig jawohl
vielleicht ist der sc sondern dann sei
das einfach nicht leute
nein das war wirklich schwierig die
arcelor alter kann ich würde
nein tico tico jetzt ok steht eins zu
drei ich habe meine ganzen punkte vom
anfang verloren sofort rücken gehen mein
gott das ist ja so eine sache man das
gehirn überließ das einfach na ja wir
waren mal den sinn hat alleine sind
genau schneit es noch nicht ich gerade
als junge tricky
ihre musik ist sicher unter druck aber
ich höre auch nicht bestehe bei minus 1
punkten das ist immer ganz wichtig das
ist ein richtiger also auf jetzt ist es
aber schnell gefällt der neue jahr
bekommt die maus den käse hey was wir
muss gucken ob die linie hinführt muss
mit dem auge verfolgen ja übertrieben
wie schnell das verfolgen wird
ja wo als ob hast du diese neue kraft
kann es fliegen gebracht werden was drin
ist was kriegen kann muss zu drücken zu
können nur sie retten und sparen
naja hab jetzt dafür ist aber trotzdem
will 32 sollte ich habe kein gutes
gefühl heute stehe du bist dir sagen ich
mache mir ist es recht ich muss jetzt
auch mitfahre okay wenn zwei gleiche da
sind muss zu drücken
foto ddp naja ich nicht damit gerät ja
jetzt eine reihe durch die wir sind da
eher 7 zu 3 müssen verlängern video mehr
effektiv mir drei minuten bleibt er ist
ja wohl hier ist kanada anrainer und war
einmal war es ist ein schwieriger fall
abstrakten mein gott ja wohl leider das
ist richtig so schnell gezählt
ich hoffe dass ich hasse das was muss
man drücken wir die gleich lang sind ja
nur wie schmid ist kann man ganz auf die
fusion die junge als auch optische
illusion
ja ich habe ja ja ein bisschen später
geklickt auf jeden fall das zu kraft
tritt was aber das ist kein fall hier
das richtige meint fasst man da nein na
ja vielleicht sogar verdammt ist sehen
oder wie ich bin bei 2 wieder ja bis
zehn verdammten wochen ein punkt aber
wartet der hier ist richtigen bei acht
minuten nicht bis zehn nicht bis 10
nein das geht es schnell die spiele bis
15 und die frage wo gott nein
safe
ja ich weiß oder ist dass australien das
walter gameplan die radregion türkei
jawoll tag einplanen die kubanische
flaggen der serie ist jetzt ist es gut
dass meine akkus trend findet das
fahrzeug welches den lang lkw mit
anhänger ist die warsteiner sein ich bin
bei einem punkt wieder ich hab so
verloren schon gegen den anhänger die b
10 anhänger den doppel ak w da ist also
weiter dass das gegenwärtige niveau das
es mir auf deiner seite deswegen ist es
uns ja ist alles da seid ihr schon alle
zu dir von iris anders sind auch die
unschwer falcao ist also kommen
alte tricky müssen auf den button hat
auftritte bewegten und belegt dass ich
bei mir
da war auch leute ich glaube ich zwei
punkte was aber wenn ich das irgendwie
schaffe dann durch kommentare wort
voyeure trick das ist ein richtiger mein
vater der seine essen schlafen hinlegen
wird
jetzt mario haas war wieder gleich teuer
ist also zeitgleich aber geiles spiel
und die hauptstadt nicht verloren hat
das war auch so zeitgleich kuba war ja
du hast 510 ps
alter schwede hatte mein gott jetzt aus
haben sich streckt ist echt anstrengend
15 4
lasst auch in jedem fall jetzt ein
leichter leute wenn sie ihr euch halter
so viel zum thema ebenbürtig aber klar
ist ich habe am anfang
ich habe glaube ich viel mehr verloren
als zu viel mehr punkte
ja du hast dann fang ich richtig was man
hat das hat mich von 3 3 auf 3 -1 und
wasser auch die sache ist wenn man sogar
bis dann verlieren ist dann ist das
mental ein schüler schwierig da denkst
du scheiße scheiße scheiße scheiße
scheiße damit ihr mental keine verlierer
sein könnte jetzt diesen kanal
abonnieren will ich auch machen
ich bin euch auch jetzt noch mal umfrage
ein wo ihr abstimmen könnt ob wir mehr
mobile gaming sehen wollt und oder würde
ich sagen sind wir beim nächsten mal
wieder haut rein bis dahin und always
said